bonsoir régine torrent merci de répondre
à nos questions à chaud comment est-ce
que vous réagissez à cette cérémonie
d'investiture particulière évidemment
crise du coronavirus oblige avec des
drapeaux plutôt qu'avec des personnes
avec l'absence également de donald trump
qui vient d'atterrir en floride et avec
le discours également de joe biden
effectivement c'est une
c'est une investiture complètement il
n'existe d'ailleurs
bonsoir grégory petitjean je ne vous ai
pas saluer oui oui c'est une
c'est une investiture et que sa maman
inédite c'est la première fois qu aux
etats unis le devant du capitole est
vide alors c'est merveilleux ce qui a
été fait remplacer les personnes par des
drapeaux et alors ce qui est étonnant
devant le capitole il y a le drapeau
américain
mais il ya plusieurs drapeaux américains
il y a le le drapeau avec toutes les
étoiles
il y a le drapeau avec treize étoiles
aussi qu'il date c'est le l'ancien
drapeau lorsque il n'y avait que très
états et donc c'est un il retrace
l'histoire
et puis ce lincoln monument précédé par
toutes ces lumières qui représente le
peuple américain alors il n'est pas là
le peuple américain est absent mais il
est représenté alors l investiture et
effectivement elle pouvait être très
souvent ce que j'ai remarqué c'est que
cet homme qui à 78 ans a monté les
marches du capitole
mais alors qu'il marche qui monte vers
le capitole
mais il était droit il était c'était pas
un homme
essoufflé et fatigué par ce grand
escalier j'ai trouvé ça admirable et
extrêmement émouvant
jean torrent vous restez avec nous
évidemment pour commenter toutes ces
images que l'on voit en direct joe biden
dont qui appelle
à l'unité comment est-ce que vous
réagissez au discours de joe biden
régine toren discours de 20 à 30 minutes
donc centré sur l'unité dans une
amérique meurtrie par parle attaques
contre le capitole le 6 janvier dernier
oui c'est la première tâche c'est ce
qu'il avait prévu
c'était tout ce qu'elle souhaitait
depuis des mois d'abord recoller les
morceaux dans cette amérique qui est
maintenant fracturée c'est sa première
tâche qui sera extrêmement importante
parce que 74 millions de personnes
convoquées en voté pour donald trump
alors évidemment maintenant après les
incidents du capitole
les supporters de donald trump seront
sont sûrement un petit peu moins
nombreux mais de toute façon il doit
composer avec il doit composer aussi
avec un sénat qui est majoritairement
démocrate mais à une voix près celle de
kamala harris alors de toute façon il ne
peut pas il ne peut pas travailler seule
elle sera obligée de travailler avec les
républicains
sa tâche va être difficile les premiers
temps parce qu'il ya cette procédure d'
impeachment qui va monopoliser le sénat
il sera obligé d'administrer le pays par
décret dans un premier temps enfin par
décret ce sont des lois fédérales
ce ne seront pas des ce sera des lois
qui concerne l'administration mais qui
ne concerne pas les états alors la tâche
ne va pas être simple mais il a prévu 2
s'y attaquer en priorité et c'est vrai
que c'est le plus important maintenant
surtout quand on a écouté ce que disait
donald trump en partant je vais revenir
quand il a salué les journalistes qui
étaient devant la porte de la maison
blanche quand il est sorti il leur a dit
ce n'est qu'un au revoir
bon il a été un petit peu plus humble
déjà quand il était devant air force one
devant quand il a fait son discours de
qui a été très bref et ensuite il y
avait quand même lorsque un petit peu
d'humilité quand l'avion a décollé on a
entendu mailloux et maintenant ifaith
maintenant le rideau final tombe il le
regard sur sur sa vie sur la voie qu'il
a empruntée
donc c'était il n'a pas non plus la
musique militaire comme il le souhaitait
il avait prévu d'avoir des musiques
militaires il n'y a pas eu l chiffres
quand il l'a après l'avion donc c'était
why m6 et c'était aussi c'était quand
même alors la première chanson
n'abandonnez pas continuer à y croire
ensuite bon ayem seuil et qui est
terminée tous ces concerts et my way
était quand même à 12,6 et un petit peu
son départ et ses velléités de rester de
revenir et de dire je suis toujours là
je pars mais ce n'est qu'un au revoir et
puis de toute façon je vais constituer
un autre parti maintenant celui des
patriotes alors de toute façon
maintenant joe biden doit composer avec
avec tout ça et c'est pas simple parce
que joe biden tire la couverture à lui
c'est à dire que les médias vont encore
se concentrer sur ce que fait donald
trump
ils tirent la cote donald train peut
rester dans l'actualité il va faire de
l'ombre à joe biden dans un premier
temps et puis surtout il ya cette de
procédure d' impeachment qui risquent de
traîner en longueur
il sera le premier président à être s'il
est frappé de cette procédure il sera le
premier président celui qui a failli
être frappés de cette procédure
avant lui c'était le successeur de
lincoln
c'était andrew johnson et andrew johnson
sont posées il a été considéré jusqu'à
maintenant enfin jusqu'à un avenir très
train ressens maintenant on peut changer
de peut changer de casting mais andrew
johnson était considéré comme le plus
terrible président américain il
s'opposer systématiquement à toutes les
décisions du congrès et donc il a été
frappé de cette procédure d' impeachment
mais il n'avait pas eu le temps de
nommer un vice-président lorsqu'il a été
frappé de la procédure d' impeachment et
donc il n'a il ya échappé à l'avenir
l'avenir régime torrent pour pour donald
trump c'est quoi exactement quand il dit
je vais revenir d'une manière ou d'une
autre donald trump qui à atterrir du
côté de la floride
enfin en fin d'après midi heure
française
oui je vais revenir il va revenir parce
qu'ils font de notre parti il fonde un
autre parti donc il veut rester dans
l'actualité
il sait très bien faire de l'ombre aux
vins publiant sans blanche parce que non
il va faire de l'ombre à donald trump va
faire de l'ombre à joe biden puisque
tout la presse les médias risquent de de
ceux de se concentrer sur ce que va
faire donald trump maintenant donc je
crois qu'il faut il faudrait le laisser
un petit peu un petit peu à l'écart
quand même maintenant mais en même temps
on ne peut pas choisir la place des
médias mais pas sur les médias feront ce
qu'ils voudront mais ils risquent de
suivre donald trump au jour le jour pour
savoir ce qu'il va faire est-ce que son
parti va être constituée avec qui il va
le constituer est-ce que les tous les
républicains vont le suivre dont la
procédure qui se prépare dans les modes
sprint il manque 10 est républicain pour
que la procédure soit votée alors déjà
il y en a eu 10 à la chambre des
représentants il en manquera 17 au sénat
pour que les deux tiers soit effectif
donc il va continuer il continuera à
être dans l'actualité et c'est ce qu'il
veut il reviendra il reviendra de cette
manière il l'occupera et occupera le
terrain
jean torrent rester avec nous ces
décrets vous les avez évoqué tout à
l'heure et gilles taurand 17 décret qui
va signer tout à l'heure joe biden pour
revenir sur le chapitre donald trump
pour tourner la page
oui bien sûr il va il sera obligé dans
un premier temps comme il veut être
extrêmement rapide il va il va signer
des décrets mais qui ne concernerait pas
les états alors ça c'est ça va être ce
sera une tâche extrêmement difficile
pour joe biden parce que le pays est
fracturée il n'a pas la majorité il à la
majorité oui mais enfin elle et elle est
très très juste
il a prévu un programme très important
et ce programme est absolument
nécessaire
on a vu quelques réactions chi chi une
réaction disais bon on va pouvoir
respirer maintenant c'est bien alors que
que va-t-il se passer
il faut qu'en camp surtout donald trump
disait je vais revenir le je vais
revenir je serai toujours là il est
quand même très il est quand même
présent ce qui me fait un petit peu peur
c'est ce mouvement qu un jeune qui est
extrêmement présent aux états unis mais
partout dans le monde
ce sont des personnes qui sont vraiment
endoctrinés donc il est il va rester
présent et dont joe biden va gouverner
il va pas gouverner il va diriger un
pays
dans cette ambiance qui est quand même
hostile par certains côtés il ya quand
même une maj une une partie des états
unis qui lui sont hostiles
il aimait aux jo il aimait donald trump
aisée mais cet homme qui représentait la
puissance donald trump représenter notre
rêve
quand les américains c'est à dire un
homme qui arrive de on ne sait pas où on
lui l'arrivée de la télé réalité et qui
accède à la présidence
et ça ça fait rêver les américains dans
l'amérique profonde
il adorait ce couple cette femme
ravissante et puis cet homme qui a
incarné la puissance et eux ils
n'étaient pas tellement touchés dans
leur quotidien ils ont leurs terres et
le nom ils ont quand même pâti de d'une
démesure financière de donald trump
parce que en fait ces mesures ont
beaucoup favorisé les entreprises mais
pas tellement les pas tellement la base
des états unis donc le clivage est
encore plus important est maintenant
divisée qu'est l'amérique à
l'international régine torrent parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de 2
de réaction qui commencent à arriver la
russie qui déclarent espérer travailler
de manière plus constructive le premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
qui appelle le nouveau président joe
biden a renforcé l'alliance
le premier ministre britannique
également boris johnson qui
dit être impatient de travailler avec
avec joe biden et
d'un point de vue international à quoi
est-ce qu'il va falloir s'attendre
joe biden est un atlantiste joe biden
justement veut revenir vers vers
l'europe dont le toute façon ça ne peut
être qu'une bonne surprise
et encore ce ne sera pas une surprise
parce que les pays européens s'attendent
a justement travaillé à retravailler
maintenant avec les états unis et donc
avec joe biden ce qui ne se faisait pas
avec donald trump
donc c'est une attente qui est très très
forte en europe et partout dans le monde
il va renouer les liens
il a il dit le retour à l'om est ce le
retour dans les accords de paris donc il
est attendu
et puis il va il va arriver et donc
alors comment les relations vont se
passer on va le savoir dans les
prochains jours un bon je peux pas vous
dire pays par pays ce qui va se passer
dans l'avenir maintenant mais de toute
façon il est tout le monde veut
retravailler avec lui et tout le monde
veut ouvrir le dialogue de nouveau avec
les états unis et avec joe biden avec il
est quand même très très aidée aussi
il sera très appuyé et très soutenus par
kamal la russe qui parlent français
allait tailler dans une école française
au canada
son secrétaire d'état par le français
aussi
donc ils savent a énormément facilité
les choses ça va énormément faciliter
les relations avec l'europe et avec la
france merci origines torrent d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes à
historienne spécialiste des des états
unis